[Music]
there's a man who cuts off
both of his legs under a train in order
to claim a 2.4 million pound insurance
payout what a [ __ ] idiot dude wait
but did he get the money uh i bet he
didn't get the money
i'll put i'll put my [ __ ] life on 2.4
million will you put your legs on it
yeah i will 2.4
would you do a million pounds nick oh
that's even more than dollar stone was
this man an idiot to you before he was
legless or is it after he's legless
you insensitive [ __ ]
yeah what do you what do you got against
legless people no no just
what say it again anthony what do you do
a man cuts off both of his legs under
the train in order to claim a 2.4
million pound insurance payout he should
have put his head on the [ __ ] track
dude he should have put his tongue on
there he finished the job guy he should
have insured his brain
2.4 million dollars
pounds not yet pounds is actually
3 million oh okay talk to me
3.2 million dude damn the pound has
really dropped
yeah it's actually dropped a little bit
i used to be like 1.5 almost it used to
be two it needs to be 2x the pound
was like
mommy man wow well in this in this uh
insurance
fraud
yeah see what an idiot a court has the
term of the defendant named only a
sanders seed due to strict local privacy
laws purposely lied down in front of a
train so he could pocket the cash in
2014.
shocking incident meant both his legs
were amputated from the knee down and he
has been using prosthetic limbs and
remained wheelchair bound ever since
now this 54 year old resident of the
hungarian village
claimed to have climbed onto the tracks
so a train would run over both of his
legs he's his own damsel in distress
puts a little dress on his legs
safely please
oh no that's is that your best hungarian
accent hungarian
i think
imagine thomas looking at this guy and
he's going like this and then blood
smells on his face
he's like his legs and he's he goes very
oh yes
it is i think i can these [ __ ] don't
know really i don't know the [ __ ]
lines dude
thomas is trained infamous for the i
think i can't quote i had to dig deep
anyway baby
i had to [ __ ] find it somewhere
inside myself anyway
all right so he's down two legs now what
sorry i'm bringing my [ __ ] thomas to
train now what's the one i'm thinking
about then the blue [ __ ] it's
the same one i don't remember his show
interesting that thomas is like
privileged with all these [ __ ] wheels
he has like 20 [ __ ] five wheels but
he gets to talk about oh how this guy is
doing with his negative limbs
made him niche what i'm saying it's kind
of [ __ ] up actually i don't know he's
like a centipede but with wheels thomas
has so many wheels he could give away
like 17 wheels and he'd be fine
and he just [ __ ]
chops off the only two [ __ ] legs he's
got he's he's
he's monopolizing the wheels you know i
came out with this okay you know being
stupid ass thomas [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
thomas past central district court made
the ruling on november 9th seven years
after
this full loss is less seven seven years
the ships would probably grow back by
then
what the lizard okay
suspicions were first raised when the
authorities were told that he had taken
out 14 high-risk life insurance policies
in the year building up to the incident
this [ __ ] is so obvious
and he claimed that he took out the
policies after receiving financial
advice telling him returns are better on
insurance policies than saving his
accounts
yo he's got a solid financial advisor i
mean that wasn't a false statement right
can you like
double insure something because what is
his plan apparently you can 14 inch or
something
a car seven each leg have your car
insured by like five different companies
but if you get a car accident get paid
out five times i don't know bart i don't
have three cars like you do you tell me
no five insurance on one car dude i have
one car because i sold one of my cars
for crypto
you had two cars to start you [ __ ]
rich ass desperate i'm at the end of my
rope
you understand
after the incident his wife applied for
the payoffs but the insurance companies
refused to cough up anything anything
saying they suspected he had inflicted
the injury on himself and his wife
recorded saying what no
what are you talking about
imagine the insurance you're looking at
in a wheelchair like
i don't know about this [ __ ] that's yeah
we stand on the army
they're like you did it to yourself i
wasn't driving a train
you know you know
it's gonna take a dark turn legs we're
on the track
i don't think it's pretty funny right
now
because we're thinking this con artist
came up with a stupid idea to do it
himself
i don't think he came up with it on his
own i think he owes a lot of money
because he's a [ __ ] gambling addict
to the mob yeah and they forced him to
do something like this to pick up ah
you're thinking like cinema now that's
probably true
cinema that's a very good scripting is
dark no i think that's hot no that's
true
i think yeah
a lot of these insurance scams are
actually because people can't pay
anymore and they don't know what to do
and they're like well here's a solution
because we either break your [ __ ]
legs or you break or they cut out as
organs i can hear the de niro monologue
right now over here so i had to lay down
the tracks so you can sacrifice my legs
i can hear the trailer what could push
one man to lose two legs
i could also hear the logic fight break
my number you can't break what i've
already lost
bruce willis and matthew mcconaughey are
the legs
legless
with the legs they play the legs
they're always at odds with each other
yeah they hate each other dude and then
the sad endings they both get cut off or
they have to work together to not to
stay together have you guys heard of the
blindness thing where people like pour
bleach in their own eyes because they
want to be disabled yeah it's this weird
oh the um where they're obsessed with
like they're obsessed with like the the
lifestyle for some reason the sympathy
that you maybe get that they think you
get even though it's [ __ ] but yeah
they believe that and so they pour
bleach in their own eyes and try to like
make themselves part of that community
so that they can get like a little bit
of grift or whatever dude there's
there's a group of people not a group of
people they're like blind posers yeah
but they did it but they're really blind
now
they are they are blind but they're like
they're like blind activists thank you
they're like the ones that try to steal
the thunder you know like the straight
people at a gay parade and it's like get
the [ __ ] this is not your day first of
all that's me so chill yeah just go just
sit in the sidelines and [ __ ] hill
that's me and bart
you don't have to stand on a float bro
you can just stand on the side i know
did you see this dude who um he has that
that i guess it's like a dysmorphia
thing where they feel like they
shouldn't have limbs so they don't want
them
and this dude uh he identifies with
limbless so he's like yeah no yeah
that's really what it is it feels guilty
but it's like it's still considered a
mental [ __ ] maybe in the future by
dysmorphia or whatever but then he uh to
try to get his legs amputated he he took
a [ __ ] in a pot and boiled it put it in
a syringe and injected both of his legs
with his own [ __ ] why to make to
like uh yeah to infect it and get him
and they got chopped off why don't you
just poop his pants and leave it for a
couple days
why do you go on a train dude
why didn't he just get him chopped off
without the infection i think that was
the only way they would do it because
you're gonna have to get a medically
done because they're not gonna go oh
like oh you believe you shouldn't have
legs okay here you go so he cheated the
system yeah what a smart guy he did it
really well then he boiled his poop i
don't know if that was just a [ __ ]
fever dreamer like really give him
i have friends that work in hospitals
and sometimes they say that
they have certain people that come in
who inject themselves
with their own feces or like other
bacteria so they could be
in a state of uh sickness all the time
so they keep going back to the hospital
because they like they like being in an
emergency room it's those [ __ ]
saltine crackers isn't it
it's it's the jello actually
it's the fruit cups no but it's like
there's there's a mental illness where
people feel like they they like you know
what they should get with the people
that be poisoned [ __ ] people to keep
them sick oh like eminem's mommy [ __ ]
new dating app
that's what you do you set them up
willing hostages
yeah wheeling hostages
it's like that it's like that uh stephen
king movie what's it called with yeah
where she breaks his little anglers of
course
secret window yeah yeah
jurassic park yeah yeah yeah with the
dinosaurs
[Music]
you